a dream is if you're [ __ ] flying or
oh you got chicks all over you you know
that's it's there's a difference between
a goal and a dream a dream is a long
time
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola With Me George Lopez let's do the
show because I got a lot of things to do
things
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Robert George Lopez oh my God OMG
oh my God
this episode of oh my God hi is brought
to you by zipx toothpicks so
zippix
brings you a totally satisfying
convenient flavorful way to curb
cravings and relax with two milligrams
and three milligram options okay so
um
I've been using zipx Aaron gave me some
there's one for energy there's one for a
calm and uh I'm gonna tell you guys
space Island clove nicotine toothpicks
you want to smoke less there's every
different kind and I would say to you
peppermint watermelon see zippers they
put [ __ ] on a bottle of oil you can put
whipped cream on your bottle but it's it
fix has found a way peppermint
watermelon not like when you don't take
a bath
um so zipix I have them in the car had
them in my in my jacket had them on the
show and I'm gonna tell you something
zipx
Works go to zipx2fix.com today and use
code omgh hi to save 10 off your order
that's zipx toothpicks.com promo code
OMG hi must be 21 years or older to
order zip Morse smoke less with zipx
toothpicks
it's been your dream your whole your how
long uh I don't think I don't think it
probably
since before I retired from police work
I I really got into listening to
Mariachis I love them I love the culture
I love their music and I never used to
listen to the words that much right you
know a matter of fact I just got done
watching this thing on Vicente Fernandez
yep uh anciente and that uh
what is it yeah I always thought because
I never listened to the words I always
thought the song they played every every
concert you go to what is it what is it
about it is like come it means
I always thought since I never listened
to the words I thought it was returned
to Mexico you know everybody's screaming
so I thought everybody wanted to go back
you know the the Bison from here wanted
to go back to their country it was about
him returning to his love to his love
and so it had uh
[Music]
I looked it up on YouTube it even showed
uh at his funeral
his wife uh kukita yeah kukita was right
there look still looks nice she looks
nice the three sons were there and the
stepdaughter that he raised and uh
Leonardo I think that was Alejandro
Alejandro the youngest son
everybody had their hands on the casket
one of the brothers just crying his
heart out and he's saying
and so did you cry when your son no no
well I got a lump in my throat but I
didn't cry maybe that was just mecco
from the night before
foreign
but one time this guy said I said hey
this big dude I said why don't you be my
security guy man oh man I'm a lover I'm
not a fighter I said all right well if
somebody attacks me you can blow them
how about that pretty good hey pretty
good the uh am I buy a pretty good iron
get [ __ ] just stick oh my god
um yeah I think you know
um
I think Vicente Fernandez is
I mean there's some great like there's
some great Mexican
singers but
they're so the history of that music is
so rich better than all these guys like
guys that you would like rock and roll
like you say Buddy Holly better than fun
to die I think in a plane crash uh so
there's guys that mimic the rock and
roll but then as obscure as rock was in
those days this music is still I would
say obscure and it's for weddings and
funerals and baptisms nobody has it
because Mariachi is over because after
the game let's go outside and listen to
mariachi music you know just but but but
rich and and a and a deep
seated thing if you know if somebody you
know it's almost like when Scientology
takes somebody that's kind of wants to
be a alternative homosexual you know
they try to scare you straight you know
if you take somebody who's disconnected
from their culture
and want to know if there's any hope for
them
you listen to mariachi music and if they
have no reaction like mine hates
Mariachis like clowns so people hate
clowns mine hates Mariachis and you see
that you they can't be turned like I got
you know I'm proud of who I am I have to
go in there you know and you can't turn
them but
I mean everybody some of my men I was
never I mean I have Mariachis on tour
with us they opened pretty much anytime
we can find them
and
I I can still I can I can still remember
Saturdays
Sundays backyard parties
Mariachis playing the look at my
grandfather's face
and my grandmother and just that music
being in the house like always and and
played audible you know I've never I
played music in my room turn that [ __ ] I
thought it wasn't even [ __ ] high it
was in a [ __ ] high yeah that's why I
think I don't turn the music up when I
listen to it in the car and I think that
in the guitar I can play without an app
it's just years of somebody [ __ ]
saying turn that [ __ ] off I never
listened to it as a kid and my dad
he had a favorite song you know when
that played what was your dad's favorite
song yeah and I never paid attention to
the words
the first time I heard El Rey after my
dad had passed it brought tears to my
eyes because that reminded of my dad
then I started listening to the words
and [ __ ] that's a Mexican Macho
nationality goes to the king yeah it's
like it's like with money or without
money it's like I did it my way as the
Mexican I Did It My Way exactly I'm
Still The King and so I love that song
and that was my dream I wanted to play
guitar
and I've sang El Rey in front of people
before
but and I don't know how people do sing
and play guitar at the same time but I
want to do I don't know how they do it
either I want to do that and I just so
you had your first lesson we're talking
about girl had his lesson in itaron
that's right that he wants to be a a
secret desires to be a mariachi
first of all I don't think you're gonna
find a suit yourself
you got to play in your own clothes
[Laughter]
all right but don't always give the
biggest guitar to the littlest guy
there's no you know when they give out
the instruments here are you it's like a
big-ass guitar
um and how long do you think it'll take
you to learn
can we bring your coach in here I think
he'll be in here and we can see your
progress
I don't know I'm afraid I'm afraid for
him to take my way
it fits in here with all of us in here
I'll bring him I'll bring him in when
you bring it in it well you keep will we
keep updates and I'll bring your guitar
I was gonna bring a guitar today I told
him I matter of fact I told him I said
George's gonna [ __ ] in his pants when I
tell him no I love it I love it because
I think I think first of all I don't
think anybody's ever too old to not want
to do something they've always aspired
to do
you know 69 a lot of us you know just
simple 16.
you know you just need another person
that's
okay if I could you know you know you
know how you could use a tin can as a
base you know there's nothing like
having a real person there you know a
lot of times you know you're older by
yourself it's like using the crushed can
as a base you need a real person
oh yeah I like that Aaron
you need a you need your cat a real base
is a real base not a [ __ ] leftover
Sunday [ __ ] alley type yeah I uh I
look forward to I practice I've been
practicing uh I want them and that's an
acoustic guitar it's not yeah it's
acoustic all that stuff is all of
Mariachi instruments are yeah it's it's
acoustic
I I does it make you feel like you know
when you when you took the lesson let's
say when you took the lesson
and
the lesson was over because you already
done something you wanted to do a lot of
times people would be like
they quit in the middle of the less ah
man you know what Matt is too hard it's
first it's the first lesson you know
when you got in the car how did you feel
I could hardly wait for the next lesson
there you go I could hardly wait for the
next and I can hardly wait to practice
here's your homework practice this right
and I could hardly wait to practice yeah
and I was only stymied by Thanksgiving
Day being in the middle you know the
kids around yeah if not even today I was
out before I left did he give you uh
yeah I know man because you know it's
it's there's a satisfaction in going
down now you're going down that road and
and and you're only playing for yourself
but also
wouldn't it be great to play that for
Pearl oh yeah she she's She is totally
supportive my kids are supportive uh
matter of fact my my oldest daughter
said
dude I'm really glad you're finally
doing it Dad it's good for you do it I'm
so happy for you
so how big is it's a big man it's a
pretty big deal it's pretty big it's not
it's not heavy at all it's light and
acoustic uh and does mariachi music have
have music like chords and all that yeah
because I would think Mexico
[Laughter]
that can read music that [ __ ]
should work on SpaceX because you got to
be the smartest [ __ ] guy I'll be able
to read it incred I can't hey I'll be
able to read it once I learn what the
notes are called because there's a
looking on YouTube a lot God bless
YouTube and YouTube you know like my I
call them in Maestro the other day my
Maestro he's telling me okay this is an
a this is a g
guitar chords I I don't know because I
don't know anything about chords I don't
know anything about guitar chords I've
never played guitar don't anything and
there's no you know on guitars you have
the little whatever the little dots are
called yeah okay you don't have that the
Frets called
Frets are the little bright markers
yeah okay you don't have a real name but
for the front markers you don't have
those oh it's all sound but it doesn't
have even the things that separate no
there's nothing there uh what are those
called Aaron
those are the Frets the little the
little bars no wonder I'm not learning
[ __ ] guitar that's those those are
the Frets it has No Frets has no dots
mine
and the neck says
and it's just wide open it's like it's
like driving in Korea no [ __ ] that
you need those out there no and Alhambra
no no lights
you could go on the other side of the
road they don't give a [ __ ] there's
nothing now there's nothing like Frets
hold you into number five seven you know
like you start to reach charts uh with
the guitar uh that I'm looking at
Youtube it'll be it'll be five three
five seven five three and then if you
know it you can you can see how they put
it together but it's primitive you see
they ever look at the court the tabs oh
yeah it's primitive right but it works
it's primitive but it works and if you
start to do that and start to get good
at that you can look at anything and and
say oh [ __ ] there it is in front of you
like uh like an understandable
um connect the dots almost like painting
by numbers when you're located and you
just you start to do that you start to
hear it and the faster you clearly the
faster you can go but that a tab is
different than a chord yeah what you're
gonna see they have chords you know
f f Major G major whatever their chords
are because I haven't gotten into that
yet
the what I'm gonna have to learn is
learn those chords those Majors you know
but everything is going to have to be
committed to memory yeah where they're
at you just got to feel be to to watch
those guys you know boom boom
boom boom to move the thing it's kind of
Poker too right by poker but so so
there's No Frets so
does he tell you worst or to
specifically put your hand or not or
just around the area no you right now
it's hard to say because we've only
learned two notes but he specifically
where to put him and he said so you're
at home just doing yes just two notes
right now that's all I'm doing yeah and
I want to learn I'm hungry for more I go
to that I get my second lesson today oh
yeah oh you're not going to the VFW no
that's on Tuesdays oh what's today
Monday oh [ __ ] so we'll go uh I'll go
today
and and
um
um does it seem does it seem impossible
to you like when you're playing this
after your first lesson oh no
it seems like I can I just I I'm just
High I just want to reach it quick and I
know I can't you know part of me says
you know quick quick the other part the
homicide says low and slow do it right
yeah you know learn it right
um I don't want to get disappointed if I
try too quick I'll get this when you
listen to mariachi music can you make
out the guitar on in the in the you can
see oh yeah I see there I sit there and
pretend to play it like if I were
playing yeah yep yep and I've done that
for years yeah but I just don't know
where these things go right
so I'm I'm congratulations and then
we'll keep we will keep track of your
progress mine too you know I take the
guitars out you know I know you do I
talk everybody you know he's always got
his guitar every time everywhere I go I
take a guitar and uh you know Danny Van
Halen guitar
yeah yeah surprisingly I take the one of
the ones he played on the road
um [ __ ]
um and you know uh since since uh the
show started or we started filming
um I started to buy guitars like like
and and good guitars like growing up you
know I would see a Les Paul like like
Peter Frampton played a black Les Paul
on on you know uh Midnight Special and
you know his main guitar was that or you
look at
uh the guy from the police plays uh Andy
sub like a Telecaster so I got a little
bit of all of them but the more I'm
attracted to
are the Gibsons like the Les Paul's you
know because they're all different wood
there's one that's from 1989 that's
heavy as [ __ ] man heavy and but it's I
think they're better when they're heavy
aren't they
what about the fender that used to be
the offender's a lot fenders are light
but they're let's suppose a different
weight
and
heavy and they're heavy but the Les Paul
doesn't have
on the back like the fenders have an
open you know Eddie Van Halen's had an
open
some of the guitars have it open in the
back and the and the last part is solid
in the back and they would do that
because of the of the Springs there and
the vibration of the wood it's all
connected to the wood
and and that's what you know resonates
the hitting the strings and the wood all
of my vibrating but um
even when I said I was going to stop
buying guitars they're just there's some
that you just can't not buy I think
especially in this time that I'm I'm
fortunate and on on the inside I looked
in there
and there's a sticker on the inside
signed and it's made by Candela by Tomas
Candela himself yeah maybe guitar I know
the the um and his son is now working
he's got a son that graduated from
Loyola Marymount yeah and he says but
and I grew up this is my business this
is just what and that's in history so
candela's music is a place that they
still make handmade guitars Flamenco
folk Latin uh they don't make like rock
and roll guitars but but I think they
have a Modelo commercial maybe I don't
know something where you saw but they've
been in business forever and that's
where everybody goes I think Willie
Nelson probably all those guys have
probably gone there Bob there you know
all doing but rarely known like I didn't
really know until you mentioned that
that there they've been in East LA for
I'm going to say a hundred years maybe
yeah the grandfather brought the music
uh brought it from Mexico
and eventually ended up in East L.A yeah
and there was grandfather in the Grand
and a dad and then the dad passed and
left two brothers nothing else and it's
still going you know when I went to when
I went to Italy uh there was a guy that
was making mosaics you know Jimmy was a
one length you know tapping breaking the
stuff and he'd make the Sistine Chapel
and he'd make you know different places
in Italy out of just the Mosaic so we
bought we bought a mosaic and then we
were talking to him and and he said that
his grandsons you know his grandfather
handed it down just great great great
down the years and that his kids didn't
want to do it and their kids don't want
to do it so he said when I die
this this whole thing that my family's
been doing will go with me
either yes or he wanted to sell me one
of those things oh my God I'll take two
of them you know uh but but you know you
can see we're something where the kids
are like I don't want to be breaking
[ __ ] pieces of tile and making a
smile or a [ __ ] Bugs Bunny out of
that [ __ ] but you know it's meticulous
work you know great work and something's
some things go when the when they when
they go they go and we're talking about
you know we talked about what like that
somebody owning great uh comic books
like a collection of comic books and
then they told the dude hey man
sell those like he was older and he
needed the money and like sell those
before you die you can pay for your
medicine you could pay for you could buy
a house you got [ __ ] millions of
dollars in these cars no you know I'm
saving them to give them my grandkids
and when he died then I give my [ __ ]
they couldn't wait to sell those things
and turn a uh Superman number one into a
[ __ ] Porsche they sold that [ __ ] the
minute all right
who do I have how many bits for the I
mean yeah it's like
you know
as much as people care about their
families and as much as all them I'm
leaving into my grant they don't get
well [ __ ] Tomas uh they won't even sit
with you you think they're gonna care
about your [ __ ] Batman first episode
Batman the monster's son and they call
him Tommy I don't know if he's a junior
or what but they call him Tommy uh
they're in the store
such a nice nice young man extremely
polite just kind big-hearted and we're
so proud of the fact he says I graduated
but my heart was right here amen and
this is what I want to do and he was
back in the back working on making
guitars amazing it's not an easy thing
like you know
uh if you look on YouTube you know all
Willie Nelson's uh guitars guitar
[ __ ] trigger yeah trigger yeah
trigger so Willie Nelson's guitar
triggered like that thing and and when
he told his name from Roy Rogers horse I
think right and when you see it it looks
beat up but it's also been repaired
more times than I think I I don't even
want to say but it's been worn down and
repaired by somebody and the guy that
repairs them
does a video about it showing up here's
trigger right here he showed and you see
the holes I mean there's holes in the
wood from rubbing and bring all the
years of playing and how he fixes it and
gets it back and there's only one of
them
only one one of the one of the ones that
Willie Nelson uses so I mean that guitar
is famous for him
and then a musician will be famous for
certain things I remember when I went to
go see Aerosmith in 1979 at the Coliseum
the singer Steven Tyler
he used to hang he used to hang scarf
herbs from or still does hang scarves
from the microphone stand nobody else
does it or nobody else has ever done it
so there we are
I'm not even 18 I'm going to be 18. and
the all the guys are running around
moving cables like the Roadies getting
ready for them to come out and a guy
brings out the stand only the stand
with the microphone in it with the
scarves and the whole
60 000 people cheered for the stand
because the the stand is like oh [ __ ]
here he comes yeah it's just a stand
with the things and and just this
[ __ ] Roar and you're like what the
what the [ __ ] was everybody getting
excited about they brought the
microphone stand out I mean it's just
like what music can do
to your mind and to your you know your
dad's music my grandmother's favorite
song my grandfather whistling and and
all of those things and then you know do
you want to get a guitar I mean Prince
bought his guitar that one he used all
his career from a JJ Newberry for like
50 bucks and he made a billion dollars
with a 50 guitar but to him that was
they even told me that's my baby right
there I said hey would you get this it's
Horner you know Horner makes it the you
know the the harmonicas they make
guitars and it's not it's it's a telecat
it's it's a knockoff of a Fender
Telecaster
and to Prince he said that's my baby
right there of all the guitars he ever
had and it's in Purple Rain he plays it
all the time played The Forum plays it
in the Super Bowl we did the thing all
and that's and that's his guitar
like that's the number one I mean Chris
was in here Chris said oh that's C1
you know Chris Perez all that stuff
but your yours will be G1 you know get
that on one and then as you start to I
guarantee you as you start to play and
start to see progress you'll want to get
a uh uh Flamenco type of a Spanish
guitar maybe yeah this guy the first
thing uh the instructor told me was he
saw me walking up with the guitar and he
thought no it's a restaurant at the
corner and he says okay first thing you
got to do lesson number one he says you
need to get a guitar case for it yeah he
says and I said yeah I know you know
I've had it nobody could touch it it was
in my Den uh it was protected because I
could see you know nobody said but it
just frightens me to see somebody so
next morning it's like a kid in the car
without not being in the car seat yeah
to a guitar lover they'll be like are
you out of your [ __ ] mind put that
thing in a case first thing I did uh the
following morning was go buy a guitar
case for it would you buy it there at
Candelas yes hey sold yeah it was the
last one they had he said during the
pandemic some people have used to
manufacture his stuff they went out of
business it was last basically amen case
he had and it's things the the guitar on
itself is not heavy but the case but the
case is heavy [ __ ]
show me a picture on your phone I don't
have a picture but it's in my car we
leave oh wait to bring it in there
but but also uh
yeah in in the yeah yeah you know the
dude hanky that this guy Henry Rodriguez
that that end up you know I think I
talked about him here
um was he had a like a like a Spanish
Flamenco
guitars I looked at it and he would walk
with it holding it in his hand and then
he became this great rock musician like
in in while we were in high school we
went to go see him and he had lost all
his weight his hair was long played like
Jimmy he played like Jimmy Page
and
he was in his room already it was kind
of a loner bit of a he wasn't an athlete
and I wonder if hanky's still around man
is it to see if we could get this guy in
here hanky Henry Rodriguez hanky from
Mission Hills at Tom Brown hey
um
because
I don't know whatever became of him but
the last time
we went to this house party
in like Mission Hills or Granada Hills
and Hanky was playing
and he was playing dazed and confused
with the bow like Jimmy Payton the song
I mean the same was had just been out
and he would go I mean I mean in the
backyard I mean Van Halen played in the
backyard parties in Pasadena
I mean in all those things
are all amazing man that a kid can be in
his room or somebody can be in their
room and teach themselves something that
they could use
like the Pioneer somebody go go gets you
know the water and somebody and then you
can learn an instrument and use that
because every every person that plays
guitar had to start from from zero
that's where I'm starting yeah
and and I told him I that it was always
my dream I want to play a ray and he
said well do you want to learn how to
play guitar only you just want to learn
how to play El Rey I said no I want to
play the guitar right I learned how to
play the guitar on El Rey will come in
I just don't want to learn El Rey I want
to learn how to play the guitar and if
anybody's out there what's the number
again
should probably put it on here somewhere
if somebody's out there and they are
starting an instrument or uh starting
something that's unfamiliar to them
um
send us a video of your
um of your of what you're working on and
we'll we'll put them up right here and
we'll look at them I think there you go
818-533-1843
818-533-1843 also if you ever banged one
of your mom's friends
you know the mom doesn't know what's
Devin doing here
what is she doing here
she's in the satisfaction business hey
so let's change the subject let's go
what do you make of the Idaho the
college kids in Idaho
have you seen have you heard what
happened no at all no
hey you heard about that right I've been
practicing the guitar on
Begley yeah
so
no no no no no no so in Idaho
these four college kids two were at a at
a fraternity party
and they go home at 1 45. two girls were
at uh a a bar and they have footage of
them at a food truck I was streaming on
Twitch so they live in this house with
six people so two roommates are already
are asleep
to come a boyfriend and girlfriend
and then the two girls that have been
drinking
um and they go get food and they go home
and then in the morning a 911 call comes
in at 11 58 in the morning and four and
those four people have been killed
brutally
with a knife and it's been two weeks two
weeks ago yesterday Sunday and the
police have no clues
all right I can't say that you know I
don't want to say there are how many
Clues they have Clues
but also what what this crime scene was
one of the most devastating one of the
craziest crime scenes anybody's ever
seen and yet in two weeks they haven't
been able to I don't know if that's a
long time or not especially now that
they expect you to catch them tomorrow
and now you have internet sleuths going
in there and you have everybody going in
there and Reporting on it but
now it's getting to a point where if the
parents you know sorry for their losses
are incredible say something about the
police now you have other people that
say that it's police bashing because of
course in our culture you you you can't
say anything against anybody your
parents lose a child which is the most
devastating thing and if they say that
they're a bit uh uh unsatisfied or not
satisfied with the direction of the
investigation that's not police that's
not bashing the police that's that's
somebody that's lost somebody you know
in the Q shooting in in Colorado the guy
who tackled them all of a sudden they're
attacking him gun rights people I mean
it's it's a it's a wild society that
we've created for ourselves or one of
vipers and a room of you know just
people who are just only want to attack
when you look for fault you can find it
I don't care who you are what it is you
look for fault you can find it Idaho is
not known right for mass mass murder not
at all so the problem in lies number one
not saying anything bad about Idaho
Police Department
but
when you have something like that it
takes expertise you know you got to go
in there you can't send new people in
there you got to have and if they don't
have that much expertise so many you
know then you miss stuff and things just
get slower the investigation is slower
and slower let me ask you this because
because that's someone
removing I don't like the word like I
don't like the k word that's somebody
removing people
um and four people in a brutal way
is there I would say it can't I would
say it wouldn't be a college kid because
you gotta you gotta really be deranged
to do I think I mean maybe you don't
have to be deranged to do that but
there were two other girls in there that
were sleeping that didn't hear anything
going on and I would just assume if you
were young that's somewhere hard to go
for somebody being mad at somebody or
somebody wanting to Rob these girls or
somebody wanting to hurt these these
kids in that house that's it's it's much
more brutal than
taking four lives of six people that are
in the house
I mean sit there and say
chances are whoever the killer or
killers are
they know somebody in that house they're
they're connected because they let two
of them live they got in they got out
and there's some there's got to be some
kind of connection there should be and
as time goes on they'll be able to there
was a dog in there and the dog didn't
bark
um um would it be the dog didn't bark
because because they're familiar with
the person or the dogs asleep or the
dog's another part of the house there's
a tri-level tri-level house six people
in there I I don't know you know Richard
said he he was never afraid never dogs
never bother him because he could get
along with dogs you know so it didn't
bother him at all so I don't know about
the dog issue but why go in there and
kill four people and let two people live
unless you didn't know they were there
and you didn't and it just seems unusual
that they would go in go out kill and
without knowing nothing much more about
it there has to be you know
something from the outside brought in
and something from the inside taken out
so the physical evidence and and the
crime scene is so so important if it's
if it's one instrument being used yes
and you go here and then you go here and
here will there be
uh blood a connection through oh sure
there should be there should be you're
taking blood off of this person now
you're transferring around that person
now you're getting into mix your blood
and honor the third person you it's
possibilities not that they'll
necessarily find it but that those
things like that
are the things that you have to take
time for that's what I think you're
doing you know and I I've sat there on a
single murder and on an inside crime
scene you know where we spend eight
hours on a single murder just studying
and letting the crime lab do their thing
let them do their work right before we
go in and start looking if that's what
it is I think the police should say that
you know because
um
there was Defensive wounds on I think
two of the four
so that would be most likely that
whoever
did that would they have cut themselves
maybe they very well could have you know
slinging a knife or a sharp instrument
somebody's got to have some kind of
defensive wounds and if there's a
defensive someone puts any kind of a
struggle well then there's a good
likelihood that you're going to have uh
cut a Nick or something on you where
you're going to leave something physical
behind you just said something though uh
the checkpoint the police should have
said something there's a recent case
ah the the the kid that ran over the
academy class
you know a couple of weeks ago here in
in Whittier yeah and he was in shock and
you know said he fell asleep he gave and
and my daughter watched the interview
with him as I did I taped record I
wanted to see what he had to say and my
daughter was saying yeah but why didn't
he say this and why didn't the cop say
this and why did and I said
dear hold back a little bit you know why
do you have to know is there a need for
you to know right you have no idea
what's going through his mind you have
no idea what's going is it really
necessary you got people hurt somebody
may die and you know who did it
now you now your job is if
you're a cop working at his
investigation pull the evidence together
and make him or
you're also obligated to clear him if
it's not an intentional act right and he
this young kid is not under any
obligation to tell you anything I'm
surprised that he went on the news
anyway right so you just have to take
that and understand what you just said
why aren't the cops say anything
they're not obligated but they shouldn't
well they should say well we can't
answer that because it's part of an
investigation sure they shouldn't so and
response yeah and and that's the trouble
with so many agencies that aren't
equipped to handle
High uh
High news media attention you know these
things that draw the attention the
shooting uh where the the accidental
discharge on the movie set right okay
they were saying stuff in the beginning
never should have been released that's
not necessary they're not used to it I'm
not blaming them I'm saying they're not
used to
this type of media attention and so when
you get someplace in a small you know
Buck does a Tennessee
they're not used to it
they're scrambling they don't know what
uh without bad mouthing them it's a bad
thing it's just unintentional uh because
there has to be
Footprints coming in and out I mean
there has to be sure uh a door left open
I mean when somebody's if somebody's
doing that uh and they leave do they
leave consciously being aware of making
sure the doors closed but also they have
to touch something
and I can
I can almost guarantee you
first Patrol cop in Idaho that got there
got there and said oh my god look
and stopped
and then they put up this Yellow Tape
but how many more cops went in there to
take a look yeah
you can't do that yeah you can't have
anybody going there no no and and they
don't understand that ah We're Cops we
can go in they don't understand that
that that's a problem I think yeah I
think that and not only not only does
that happen there we used to have a guy
that worked with us John Yarborough was
a homicide investigator wanted to know
how many people had stepped into this Am
Pm gas station you know Am Pm there was
a robbery and a guy had been killed
and so he got there and he says he
talked to patrol them Jesus how many
people have gone inside that store
since this since he says sir myself my
trainee went in there paramedics went in
there pronounced them dead they came out
nobody else has gone in
the store video camera shows 23 people
right entered that crime scene and that
was here yeah damn where you're supposed
to know better and who belong and who
belongs in that course okay so let's say
let's say it's it's been untouched now
what I'm one call first came in and now
people are going over there
Who belongs that does a uniformed police
officer belong in that room no no and
there's a picture of one standing in the
stained glass standing in inside of the
sliding door no a uniform cop detectives
forensics forensics belong in there
forensics need to go in there they need
to study they need to clear
they need to find everything they can
without
people being inside that room they will
clear a path for you to go inside
and only they belong in there yes we're
Gathering evidence yes on the on the uh
case that I mentioned we were there out
there eight hours
we got there poked my head inside the
door
stepped back out and said wait till the
lab gets out here I need physical out
here give me this give me that and then
we nip went back inside
until after they had cleared away and I
mean off of stuff like this if this were
your floor right here you walk in there
people don't we have the ability back
then I don't know what they're using now
we something called electrostatic dust
lifter
so it's like the the film that they put
on your tinted windows right you put a
piece of tint over you put one probe
right here one Probe on this side you
hit the electron and the thing just
sucks itself to the floor
you take off the electricity jolt and
you picked it up you pick it up and you
got a perfect footprint right there on
that piece of uh paper so I don't want
to go in there and put my big buttas in
there yeah just those are for the
suspect he goes in there maybe he'll
drop some hair off his head right you
know maybe he'll spit maybe there's
something hit it up with fluorescent
lighting do whatever clear that area
every possibility you owe it to that
dead person or though in this case those
dead people to do it right once they're
done then you can go ahead and say okay
now
homicide you can come in and bring a
photographer with you
so now you got
the criminalists right a photographer
and a homicide cops nobody else has to
go in there well I think once you're
done then you call the corner corner
doesn't even belong until you're ready
to move the bodies then he goes in and
he removes the bodies and they are over
here they're extremely careful with the
way they remove the way they wrap them
so any evidence that's on them that so
it doesn't get blown away doesn't get
moved to get it back to the Corner's
office right and that's what it's got to
be
hmm
because I think I think
well there's there's a ton of officers
there and there's one standing in the
doorway of one of the rooms looking or
like looking outside I mean that guy
doesn't belong JonBenet Ramsey same
thing tons of their people went in there
the news media got to go in there the
neighbors got to go in there you know
and you can't and once you do that
everything how long does it take for
blood analysis to come back uh depending
on how busy they are you know there was
a time where it would take blood
analysis to kind of DNA would take you
know anywhere from two to three months
you know now they can do DNA returns
rather quickly on a priority and then a
shoe print or a smudge
or
you know some of the the that person's
DNA
yeah I think I think I think that house
was known as
a house that people would go if you're
in college every place you live is a
place where people go and party sure but
it doesn't look like robbery or or uh
sexual assault was an issue or robbing
anybody they're college kids
so
somebody's angry and they're just you
know and if you have that understanding
there's a reason for what they did you
know they yeah find out and you know
that throw the pebble in the in the pond
and then start with the closest Ripple
so learn victimology about the people
you got in there and that'll lead you to
your care what do you think they've
killed where do you think the person who
did this comes from
you have to know who's in there yeah
I would think with no one minimally I
would think that
and this is all speculative I would
think that somebody knew what was going
on somebody knew the the people that
were in there
this episode of oh my God hi
is brought to you by zipx toothpicks so
zippers brings you a totally satisfying
convenient and flavorful way to curb
cravings
and relax with two milligram and three
milligram options so there's one that
had like energy uh cinnamon one I put in
my mouth uh also when you were growing
up if you saw a guy with a toothpick you
know that he got a lot of good chunk
joint because like he was always relaxed
remember when massive Vape clouds
ashtrays and dip spit were awesome I
don't think so but hey you can do this
on the plane
you could sit there and you can have
this in your mouth on the plane and it's
to relax there's different ones here
there's some nicotine that you want to
stop smoking which everybody is trying
to quit smoking and somebody who hasn't
quit smoking is somebody who just hasn't
tried zipx yet that's what I would say
instead of a toke or a smoke
put a bottle in your mouth uh it's less
messy it's a subtle way to cook cravings
with zipic toothpicks and the best part
is that you can really use them just
about anywhere and see oral
gratification and amazing flavors that
will keep you coming back to zip X
they only sell their toothpicks online
making them one of the most effective
Alternatives available also if you need
a boost of energy try their energy B12
and caffeine toothpicks it's a very easy
thing to have around I put them in my
shirt pocket and they were great there
uh I used them the energy ones and
I'm going to tell you I thought it was a
brilliant idea when he showed it to me
and I've used them for uh three weeks
and I think it's still really really
great you guys have seen us use zipx on
the podcast now it's time to find out
for yourself go to zipx toothpicks.com
today and use code OMG hi to save 10 off
your order that's zipx
toothpicks.com promo code OMG hi must be
21 years or older to order
zipmore smoke less with zipx toothpicks
hey look who's here
what's up you zip through traffic what's
up what's up I can't even blame nobody
what's going on brother good to see you
that was happening
it's been a long time it has been
forever I'm sorry man that dude the song
is a [ __ ] rock right there reminded
me a lot of me that dude is solid as a
rock solid what's up dude
do you do a podcast here too yeah
um all things comedy but I do it at home
most of the time and just come in studio
when I do interviews are you familiar
with this gentleman yeah oh yes sir yes
sir you're a lover of Comedy I'm a lover
of Comedy I'm a lover of Alonso I
remember when years ago
when we first met and he was over at
Steven's Steakhouse I was working at
Homicide Bureau we used to hire him and
I thought you were doing good what you
doing over there man I'm laughing
because I had Rudy on my podcast and we
talked about that we talked about how
many gigs at Steven's Steakhouse how
many fundraisers and cop shows and this
and that I still get tickets
was your heart attached to it man I I
did it for Rudy yeah and you know he
said you ain't got to worry about
nothing I was like yeah I do Rudy they
remember you they don't remember me
there you go
that's not so I remember you brother
um pronounce your last name Bowden
but do people get that when they no they
don't so I'll tell you the story behind
that my dad is from Honduras which a lot
of people don't know that so you know I
couldn't really work the Latino angle I
look look a little too much yeah but but
I am but they're no they're technically
yeah so the island he was from you know
how people talk on the islands they're
not going to say bad and they say Boden
yeah so that's just how it's pronounced
so grammatically yeah it would be so
when somebody says Baden they're saying
it the right way yeah but the way that
it's been said is Putin right you're not
you're not related to the famous
pathologist but no not that I know of
yeah yeah he was a big big dude
nationally nationally no but yeah yeah
he's totally foreign
Spanish perfectly and English perfectly
yeah Puerto Rico you you I remember
being there and seeing like blonde blue
haired like Malibu people and then they
start talking and they're totally Puerto
Rican like okay something yeah they got
a little thought and Guadalajara same
way you walk down you don't know whether
to say widows yes or good morning
because they're blonde hair blue-eyed uh
just like they know what that tells you
well [ __ ] anything that's right the uh
the uh but is your father was your
father did he have an accent and he did
yeah he did so him and his brother and
his uncle came to the U.S in like 1939.
and um
you know they the thing was back then
when you came to the U.S you didn't
bring your culture you assimilated right
so they they look black so they just
move right into a black neighborhood and
that was it we were you know it's like
we were raised as black people I'm sure
if he came over now I would speak
Spanish and you know everything else but
back then whatever culture you were you
just Blended in
did you remember part of it growing up
was it was there things in your house
that were the only thing me and my
brother remember is how much rum my dad
and my uncle could drink like they could
drink rum like we'd be like shouldn't
they be dead like like
the two of them would sit down literally
and like when you get older and you you
start drinking right as a kid you know
you're like I don't know 14 15. you know
what I mean you're messing around and
you realize what drinking is and we
would watch the two of them just knock
out a fifth of rum and then get up and
we'd be like what so that was
that was the culture that was the part
of the culture do you feel it in your
body do you feel any part of it in your
body or no I mean I respect it now we
actually learned a lot more actually we
learned a lot of it after my dad passed
away we kind of going through the house
and go through stuff we found all of the
paperwork of like their immigration and
and pictures from back then and stuff
like that so we learned more about he
took us once down to Honduras to meet
his mom and to meet the family that was
down there so and then I went down there
again with the Uso but I went to a
different part so
it was there was a connection but not
like
not like a real connection you know what
I mean not not close enough to really
feel it now going beyond that on um
Grand Cayman there's a town called
Bowdoin town
on the island and that's where the
family's from wow so I asked my mother I
said hey shouldn't we have something
down and she's like yeah you did your
your great uncle swindled your
grandmother and sold it
down there but again this is what was
being done back then but um and then my
brother met uh talking about white guys
he met a white guy named Bowden and he's
the guy said I got a story to tell you
about our name and the guy said what
happened was
Pirates came down to Grand Cayman and
that's where they stashed everything and
that's how Bowdoin Town got started and
then the Pirates just like you said will
[ __ ] anything right so they just started
[ __ ] with them
and that is that is the history of the
name do you like Pitts do you like
Pittsburgh the baseball teamwork
you know for some reason they've been my
favorite team but yeah that makes sense
I mean think about that back in the day
that pirates would come in and and yeah
that the islands were where they all
hung out right they would hang out in
the islands and they would Rob Ships
coming back and forth to the U.S that
was yeah that was their thing so yeah
ah blow me down
I think if you gotta listen if I had a
lot of money that I stole the that's
what I'd be yelling Blow Me Down
so yes yeah that is uh that's the
history interesting man but you know you
know the thing the thing that that's
crazy in that is that like what he said
is that you come here and you can't
bring your culture with you
the people that went to Alice Island and
landed they changed their names to more
net to easier names they could pronounce
right they could say okay you're this
and they write it down and you're and
you're that and you can't you're right
you can't bring your culture because
they want you to assimilate but also
assimilation doesn't mean you don't have
to you know uh why I'm doing just jobs
right now I've my culture you know I
grew up here it's all American all
English now I'm going I want my culture
back you know so now I'm learning to
give that wrong now I want to learn this
stuff and it's all about who wants to be
about it he wants to dabble in the music
in mariachi music oh yeah so he's got a
big guitar
and uh he's he has a second lesson
tonight okay taking lessons congrats
yeah
they'll do that's why I call [ __ ] on
all these white people who like go back
to your countries like you're illegal
it's like listen when your grandfather
came over there was no paperwork he came
to Ellis Island and they said your name
is Jones and you walked into New York
you you don't know who came up you know
what I mean like you it's not like your
family came over here speaking English
with a full-time job the whole idea that
anybody would say to anyone buddy go
back to where you came from it's just
ridiculous it is and it tells you about
what
what perception someone who has lighter
skin thinks about somebody who has
darker skin when they're all the same
absolutely it's they're all the same you
know I I was down in Panama for two
weeks teaching down there and that's the
way it is down there there is no
difference between
dark skin white skin
everybody's Panamanian period right
they're they're together there is no
racial you're better than me because
you're light white it's really beautiful
I saw a guy that looked like Michael
Jordan in his prime and he was [ __ ]
Haitian
it was five six that's not Michael
Jordan but he [ __ ] looked like
Michael Jordan
a 5'6 version
and and you're just like man that dude
looks like because they're all all
derived man then the opposite is if you
go somewhere like I went to Ireland you
go to Ireland you see someone black
that's my long lost cousin I'm so happy
to see because those those countries
like everyone I joke about it but it's
like everyone in Ireland is Irish every
they're all white right they're all
O'Reilly or Hennessy or whatever you
know I mean like it those countries the
Asia when you go to Japan it's like yeah
everybody's Japanese any immigrant
stands up where did the Black Irish come
from from from Traders uh uh shipping
and stuff things yeah it had to be the
guy in thin you know Thin Lizzy The Boys
Are Back in Town and yeah all those
songs that guy Phil lynott uh he's been
gone for a long time but
he was the leader of Thin Lizzy he was
black Irish and
my dad they used to say hey Mexican come
here and my you know it worked it was
easier to jokingly my dad would sit
there and say
I'm not Mexican smoked Irish just a
little well done
and he died on St Patrick's Day
oh man see that's that's taking a joke
to the very end I like that I respect
that you know yeah like red fox red fox
was always like oh
[ __ ] it has a heart attack
coming Elizabeth yeah
um
I saw that used to work during the day
yeah and
um one of the things I think that's
great about having this podcast is you
know a lot a lot of the people that have
come in here have been younger comedians
so their their frame of reference or you
know just just their time that they have
spent in in this is different than
somebody who would work during the day
now now some of them will never have a
job other than what of what they're
doing right that's all they ever do is
and you can be good at home you can just
do [ __ ] at home
and and be good at it and make money at
it
um
when did you what day did you leave your
day job uh it actually it's coming up I
gave up my day job
in December of 92. wait this is this
2020 yeah December 92. so I was uh my
first career was Aerospace I was an
airplane mechanic
and then with the military uh no no I
went to school for it and then I go to
school from like what you see on channel
13 like where you could be a mechanic in
six months no actually no my high school
you know I grew up in New York right so
New York has had high schools for trades
you could go to I went to Aviation they
had Automotive of course the famous one
is performing arts right Fame right yeah
but you could learn you could dad like
Queens vocational you could learn to be
a plumber electrician you could learn
all the trades while you were in high
school so I went to Aviation High School
I got hired by Lockheed which used to be
right over here in Burbank shopping
center is right and um I did that I
bounced around that business for like 10
years then I started training new
mechanics and when I when I stepped in
front of the classroom like I had never
really done public speaking or anything
you know everyone gets nervous to me it
was the most natural thing in the world
just be up there and I was talking and
joking and they were laughing and I just
said you know I want to try stand up you
know and did they tell you you should be
a stand-up or did you some people did
but I'll tell you where it came from
since it's George Lopez I got to get on
you got to get real can't [ __ ]
Georgia I mean I'm the one that [ __ ]
I mean I don't require that people I
interviewed I'm gonna tell you a story
about you that I remember that you will
never uh you would never remember but
anyway
if it's from the 90s I won't remember I
went to rehab in the 80s right I went
through the whole cocaine crack thing
yeah wow and I got sober at a place
called Studio 12 right so the Stars went
to Betty Ford and the crew went to
Studio 12 right I was with the cameraman
the lighting wow the makeup and this and
that but they were the ones who like
showed me the entertainment business
they were like yo man if you want to do
this you could do it like it you know it
like if you if you're not around
entertainment and I don't know your
history how you got into it but where I
come from go to school get a job work
entertainment's the farthest thing it's
like this different world like you can't
they would like you can do that so I did
it man I took one of those writing
classes like the six week comedy writing
class and I did that first five minutes
man and just never looked back I said I
said I'm not not going to work on an
airplane again and I just started
chasing it that was uh and where did you
do your first time 93. it was a theater
in Santa Monica where they used to do a
list and yeah some other stuff the
theater's not there anymore but they
used to use it for Comedy Central I
remember that theater and during the day
they had you know comedy classes yeah
that's where I remember that place
so
um then my first job after a few months
doing Open Mic I did hope Mike at the
Laugh Factory and Jamie hired me as a
doorman that's right right so I'd be the
doorman and I get on stage that's right
and you gave me a piece of advice one
night Rodney was there and this chick
she her half her set was talking about
oh my gosh Rodney Rodney blah blah blah
blah and you said to me you said yo man
never worry about someone famous they
know who that is you do you
you tell me you said don't even mention
it he said he was like they just they
know they saw Rodney right they didn't
need you to tell them they saw Rodney
right you know yeah so so I appreciate
that you gave me that advice and and
that has always stuck with me like it
don't okay you know I'm gonna tell you
so
and that's I still believe that to this
day
so I went to an AP AIDS project Los
Angeles show at the amphitheater in the
90s and I think
band and that um Wahoo's and it was it
Jennifer Hudson when did Dream Girls
come out
was it Jennifer Hudson no that was in
the 2000s yeah it might have been the
first Dream Girls the one from Broadway
I don't remember who starred in that but
they did dream growth was on Broadway
and then later
okay uh so I go to apla
and there's an African-American woman
singing
that's only supposed to sing two songs
and
Jennifer Holliday yes that's who it was
yeah okay it was Jennifer Holliday
sings one song they go crazy
sings a second song they go crazier and
she's supposed to leave
but they're in such a frenzy standing up
cheering that she's just looking around
they say well do another song which was
only two so she does another song and
she's killing it and I sit there and I
say to myself
I can't imagine who's [ __ ] next
Who's Gonna who's gonna come out who's
gonna come out next
and who came out Robin Williams
and Robin Williams walked out
and he never mentioned her he never said
how incredible she was he just went into
doing his thing and then a minute later
it was like she was never there
and he pulled all that together and used
it for him
and he did the whole you know yeah you
know the whole all the things he used to
do and and it was the most
to me at that time was the most
brilliant thing I've ever seen
and then I do a thing with
oh man what band was that cool in the
game some some band
at a fundraiser and it's Kenny G
and then Michael Bolton sings with Kenny
G
and
one of the guys in the band says
[ __ ]
who's who's who's who's following this
and I said I am
and I went out there and never mentioned
them and did my thing and a minute later
it was like they were never there
and I saw that less and it works yeah it
does it does it works so you know I saw
that and I learned from it but also what
I like about you and and seeing you I've
never seen as a dog that's right and we
that was we always talked yeah that was
um I tell people like I had the ultimate
education because I was a doorman in the
early 90s so it would be like George
Damon George Wallace Dom Herrera like it
would just be murderous robe right that
I'm watching every night you know so
yeah and at that time you were the
dormant were you were you not you were
not working during the day anymore uh I
was hustling during the day you know
trying you know doing what my main job
actually I was a driver for the uh kids
show Power Rangers yeah so I would work
when they did location I would drive for
them and then you you know how it is you
what you got to do to pay the rent you
know yeah so yeah I was in that
transition period so so there's a lot of
different ways to go so what would you
say to somebody that you know he wants
to play the guitar I play the guitar
what would you say to anybody that is
working because I don't I mean when I
work during the day
and I knew I wanted to be a comedian
and I would sit there in this room on
Balboa Boulevard where my grandmother
worked I would sit in this room at night
or sit there during the day and think
what I want to do for a living
seems so far away to even make dollar
one first you got to be able to be good
enough to make a dollar but to sustain a
lifestyle from where I'm sitting in this
room checking off these boards
how do I how did I get from there to
here what what do you what would you say
to somebody that's that that is what
doesn't matter
people have talent and a lot of a lot of
families if you sing back you ain't [ __ ]
and you all of that means something to
somebody when you say it to somebody you
ain't [ __ ] or if somebody says you
should do it that's them telling you you
should do it but whether you do it or
not is up to you yeah and you came up we
have a lot of parallel similarities in
in how in our lives but what do you say
to somebody that even might be watched
or they know or because I just like to
know what you say to them about pursuing
what they and not even a dream a dream
is if you're [ __ ] flying or you got
chicks all over you you know that's it's
there's a difference between a goal and
a dream a dream is
[Laughter]
and the difference between a dream and a
goal
right you know what I tell them I tell
them first thing I tell them is you
gotta love it you have to love this
because
like you know people talk about how hard
we work and all the work if you love it
then that [ __ ] doesn't matter because
it's just about doing it right it's it's
about you know driving two hours for
free or to make you if you make 20 bucks
and get dinner like that's the gig or
whatever so what I would tell them is
listen you got to remember that you want
to do this you love doing this so
whatever you do during the day do what
you got to do to pay the rent I mean
hopefully you know you ain't selling
dope or robbing nobody you know right
you don't do five to ten and then have
to come out but yeah but it doesn't
matter whatever whatever gig you got to
do during the day to like now you know
this uh like I a guy who uh opens for me
in New York he's an Uber driver right
and I told him I said yo man you're
driving an Uber in New York City and
you're not doing any material about that
right there has to be some of the
craziest [ __ ] if you're driving an Uber
in New York City there have to be some
crazy people that get in your car you
got to use that you got to write that
[ __ ] down and and put it in your act but
do whatever you got to do to pay the
rent because you you have to love this
to do it man we all remember you know
making you know when you were happy to
make 50 bucks right I remember how's
this for one remember when you wanted to
work weekends remember your whole gig
was Monday Tuesday Wednesday and then
the pros work the weekend that's right
and you were like man one day I'm gonna
do Friday that's right yeah that's right
writing him
the uh um
uh
well I saw a guy I would say his name
a comedian I worked with in I think the
Improv in San Diego
and
he was the headliner and he had like 25
minutes of material about dating
and it's I'm really good strong so
afterwards the next day you know we have
breakfast and lunch you know and I said
I said
I didn't know you were I didn't know you
had a girlfriend I know you were dating
anybody goes I'm not
I just wrote material about it but I'm
not and I thought ah wow man that's
that's that's that's that's different
yeah and then in 89 when I got that
movie ski patrol and I went and I broke
away from stand up like I'd quit my job
in 88 so in 89 I wanted to ski patrol
and I didn't work for a couple months
and when I went back
I had a different perspective like it
just seemed false you know like a guy
talking about his girlfriend but not
having one seemed false and I thought
wow do you want to really kind of seem
false do you want to do are you up here
just to tell say things that you think
they might laugh at or are you here to
say things that you think are funny and
you're telling them now all of a sudden
they're telling you
what to do you're not telling them and
he's picking stuff that's generic and
um just kind of middle of the road is
always going to be safe but he he turned
out to be a safe type of comedian and at
some point people have to choose what
Lane you're going to be in
and to me at that point
it just seemed everything derived seemed
so so false that I didn't I didn't well
that's that's acting yeah that's acting
right that's acting if I'm gonna
suddenly if I'm like I'm not married and
I don't have kids and I start doing a
married with kids routine yeah well now
I'm playing the role of a dad right yeah
you know I'm not a dad I don't know
really what it feels like when your kid
throws up in the front seat of your new
car or some [ __ ] but I can I can make a
joke about it you know my mind was
throwing up one night and I put her back
to bed
Jimi Hendrix in there she could have she
could have died
and and it was just me and her and then
Anne gets home and checks on her and
there's vomit all over the bed and she
picks her up and we take her to
emergency and the whole way I had to
hear you had no idea she was throwing up
so so
to me that's more real than putting her
to bed and reading a bedtime story I
couldn't wait for [ __ ] buyer to go to
sleep right I mean the amount of
Benadryl that kid
it's a wonder how she doesn't say every
day I'm still fine is anybody else
I couldn't I only had one kid and I
couldn't wait for that [ __ ] to
go to sleep
what time is your bedtime I said
sometimes it's 11 30 in the morning
when I'm tired of [ __ ] seeing her
that's when it's her [ __ ] bedtime and
and Ann would be with her they'd be
[ __ ] playing with sand I'm like man
listen I never could never proposed to
be the best dad but when you don't want
to spend three hours of 24 with your kid
you know maybe you should have
I don't know yeah but that's honest
that's funnier yeah it's to me that's
funny to me that's what that's what it
was that's what that was that's what it
was and um have you ever been close I
mean being married guilt first of all
you know Gill's history
um no I know you I know the name I don't
tell me the Midnight Cowboy it was one
of the first dudes a hustler
oh you're that guilt
I like your Five-O I like your work in
the 70s
hey so so Gil was a detective he was a
sheriff and Gil
um almost three years ago The Night
Stalker right documentary came out and
that's you yeah okay yes I do know your
story then yeah that's right and yeah
yeah
and he's about to tell you I've been
married
this day after Chris will be 52 years
that's awesome I I respect I have
friends one friend when I went to high
school they've been together for 42.
it's a beautiful Institution
so I respect it like it's never been my
thing like I am not a relationship guy I
never the the work involved like when it
gets hard I'm like yeah but what do you
think where do you think that comes from
um how long we were Mom and Dad married
my mom and dad made 50 years wow they
passed they did 50 years how long were
your mom and dad married
[ __ ] I don't know it's over 50 just a
little [ __ ] hey man okay that died no
well no it couldn't have been fitted my
dad died at 65. and he might have been
married at 13. and he was 25 he was 25
when he got married my mom was only 15
when they got married when he was 25.
and he died at 65.
so [ __ ] do the math yeah okay so anyways
uh it might be you know people think
it's derived or or whatever but you you
no man you know well one thing was I
started comedy late right so I started
at 30. which in in our business you know
most people starting their early 20s
mid-20s whatever yeah so in that period
where most people get married and have
kids that was my man I'm glad to make 50
bucks tonight right I'm glad to be so so
I wasn't even thinking about because I
knew like if I got married had a kid now
I got to get a real job now I gotta
support that because that is what I came
from right my dad was you know the
provider and I mean my mom worked too
but you know that's what you did so I
knew I didn't want to I didn't want to
get that responsibility but did you did
you date women that knew you were a
comedian and they said is this what you
want to do for your life that what I'll
tell you what's really funny about that
the girl I was dating when I did like my
first open mic so when I first started
she said I don't know if she's a prophet
or what she said
this is going to be your wife and women
will only be your Mistresses like she
knew it then she said this is what you
this is wait a minute you were [ __ ]
Miss Cleo yeah
I told him I could think about that so I
always say that there were two women in
I've had in my life but also could that
woman have been a messenger to you
absolutely absolutely somebody that was
there to tell you absolutely what your
future was going to be yeah I believe
that there were two that I that I came
close to marrying one
it that probably would have been good
but we were both scared of it you know
she lived in St Louis I lived here it
was like am I gonna move you to El
Edition that it was the the other one is
the one where oh thank God I didn't
marry that one you know that's so those
were the two so but the one
um from St Louis like we're still
friends you know you know we're cool and
it was funny after a few years I said
you know I was just really scared to ask
you to move like to make that commitment
and she's like I'm glad you were scared
to ask because I was scared you were
going to ask and I didn't say no right
right so it's a it's a tough thing man
because you know in in stand up like
that there there is no money like
there's not enough to sustain yourself
even you know even actors you know that
I've seen that that's that one time the
actor that was in The Karate Kid and
then he did stand up at The Comedy Store
in the early 80s he was in The Karate
Kid and he said come to my apartments up
by the Hollywood uh by the Magic Castle
and he was in there living with like
three or four other actors and they're
in there and they're they got they're
looking at the tape the coffee table
and they're trying to they're trying to
pull together money to buy milk and
craft macaroni and cheese so they could
all eat and I said yeah here here's a
ten and they're like oh we'll pay you
back no no but I'm still working during
the day yeah but they were out there
just grinding and trying to make it and
when I saw that that was a sign to me I
said well I don't want to I don't want
to do it like that they think they came
from other places and they came to LA
but I was you know grew up 12 miles from
Hollywood and I thought
I [ __ ] I don't want to I don't want to
do it like that it takes it takes a
special woman to take this ride you know
they're like I'm now I work a lot with a
lot of jazz musicians and stuff like
that you know and well you know him too
you host the uh the festival the bowl
and stuff but you know one thing I
noticed with them like and I don't know
if it's just jazz music somewhere but
these guys have been married forever and
their wives are truly their partner and
I'm like it takes a special woman to
understand the travel that when you come
home even when you're in town right
you're still not home because you're
still doing spots at night and this and
then you have to put up with like I
always joke that I tell my nieces like
listen
no athletes no musicians but especially
no Comics no because if you're if you're
a Comics woman you have to put up with
the broken part
see everyone else gets the funny part
you gotta put up with the broken part
that makes us funny that's right and
that part you like you know you know I
heard a story I heard a story of
somebody that that worked on my first
show and this guy was an athlete
attractive good-looking guy like
pictures you know probably had Major
League potential
and he had a scholarship from high
school to go play baseball at a
well-established uh College
and his high school girlfriend said you
know if you go do that what's going to
happen to us
like what's going to happen to me where
are we going to go I don't want to go
and do that you know are you whatever I
don't want you to go and do that I want
you to stay with me
so he turned down his scholarship stayed
with her and she [ __ ] his best friend
and was he a pitcher or a catcher
I think he was a picture that turned
into a catcher
but uh but you know he put his he put
everything on the table for her and she
did and she did that and he never
rallied to go back around and go and get
that oh yeah it's um you know it's tough
It's a tough
light like you have to put up with like
she has to say okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
support you in this I'm gonna be with
you in this it's not even like like if a
woman supports a guy in medical school
you know if he graduates he will be a
doctor right but if you support a comic
you don't know where the career might go
it might go go well you might strike
Millions but you may get the the the
lifelong middle act you know that that
guy tour in the midwest forever because
he loves doing it right and now you have
to you you accepted that life you signed
on to that life my marriage is survived
only because of my wife truly you didn't
have to tell me that Gil even in the
little that I know you
so you mean once a chubby chaser
[Laughter]
she just uh at times there were times
she thought that I was married to the
department you know working homicide
it's it's a tough gig it's not a job
it's a lifestyle and but but also she
she also she kept it together
if somebody says to you if whatever I
mean you can say whatever gender
I don't know why you're doing this
you're just wasting your [ __ ] time
all right you're wasting your [ __ ]
time and you're wasting my time
okay get over it you're never gonna be
what you want to be listen I had a I
would just say I had a manager that was
from a a very reputable company
and they handled one of the biggest
comedians that was working at that time
NBC show
and she told me on the phone I would ask
her about showcases because back then
you would want to showcase people and
and she listen nobody else I don't
really let anybody yell at me ever
but on the phone she says you don't get
it nobody wants to see you
on the phone
and I was like wow man nobody's ever
said that [ __ ] to me
and then
somebody wanted to see me I got The
Tonight Show in 91 Arsenio was in 89 and
then I kept kind of making my steps and
my way through and in the late 80s
I would have to agree with her nobody
wanted to see me but that didn't mean
that I didn't have value it just meant
that I needed to look at myself I think
and see what was I was worried about
what everybody else was doing
uh and once I changed to thinking about
only I'm gonna do what I do and I don't
care what anybody else does I think
comedians also like anything [ __ ]
nurses doctors whatever that ain't [ __ ]
you see you know and the fact and the
second that I let everything go of
saying that you know on unflattering
things about somebody and didn't worry
about what anybody else was doing
everything changed yeah yeah for me
early on my thing was always what did it
how did you get to the next level you
know I mean like like if I'm doing the
the twenty dollar you know yeah and
where did you get give me your first
level let's talk about LA and then on
the so la was it was the open mics it
was like there was a bowling alley in
Canoga Park there was a bookstore in
Hollywood there was a coffee shop there
was the back of a Cuban restaurant in
West L.A and then then a lot of those
East L.A gigs with Rudy the the the bars
and the you know one-nighters and those
were good because those you started
getting paid and
um
so so it started out with doing that
and then Tommy Davidson uh was probably
my first big break Tommy took me out
with him and I was opening for him for
about six or eight months and that got
me into clubs that got you know because
back then it's in the 90s so kids you
have to Google this we used to have to
send out tapes right when you send them
VHS tapes out and nobody you thought
that nobody looked at it then you had to
call up and follow him up nobody looked
at him then you had to call up and
follow up so getting to go out with a
headliner they saw you live which was a
huge difference and then that got me
into uh being kind of a Road Middle
right you know and and B clubs and stuff
doing those gigs where you got to be off
stage by 9 30 because the dancing starts
you know and and the show the show
didn't fill up till 9 15 because that's
when everyone was showing up for the
club they didn't even know there was
comedy
so doing those doing those Bob zany gigs
up and down California you know that's
why I tell everyone body when they talk
about you ever been to Hemet hell yeah
I've been to Hemet you know I've worked
the one-nighter so it was that and then
my big break was uh JFL I got new faces
in 97 I was four years in and I did new
faces and and I got a deal because back
then they were doing that and that's
when I you know quit the day job but I I
always say that that was nice as far as
quitting a day job and stuff but what
happened was that's when I got accepted
as a comic that's when people that's
when you're not doing anything but
comedy and and the people look at you as
a comic they look at you different now
when you come to the factory or The
Improv or whatever because now it's not
like you're not like a rookie trying to
get in you're like yeah you're a comic
you know this is right sure so so that
was my uh that was my break in my early
days so they had it just for laughs they
still have it in in Canada where you do
Montreal you do uh just for laughs
Comedy Festival and uh and you get to
get you have to audition right they
would come yeah yeah they it was crazy
how it works so you do a showcase
in like March or April
and then and this is before the internet
right so this is when new faces really
was kind of a secret like they didn't
you didn't know it was right and you
wouldn't hear from them until like the
end of June right and then they'd say
okay you got new faces you're going to
Montreal on such and such a day but they
were like but don't talk about that you
they didn't want Even though some people
knew but they did really that was going
to be we're going to introduce you to
the industry right there and that's
where they would go that's where they
would go and watch producers managers
all of those people would be in Montreal
and they'd be wondering who was new
faces like they put us in a separate
hotel from all the regular comics and
Festival attendees and stuff and then
you do your show and it was like this is
your debut and um I did it with
um Willie barceno was on my Year Laurie
kilmartin uh KP Anderson you know some
of the people yeah I remember but yeah
we just came out and you did it I was
fortunate that I didn't know
to be nervous wow you know I mean like I
mean I knew it was a big deal but I
looked at doing it as a set right right
so so
that helped me because and you know you
always remember the type of person that
would get nervous like that would Pace
or sometimes I would yeah I mean yeah
obviously being a new comic you're going
to get nervous yeah but I did I had this
joke right and I said um I don't like
hockey right so you're in Canada you say
I don't like hockey exact crowd and I
was like shut up shut up I don't like
hockey because the only thing black is
the puck I said but golf on the other
hand right so that was a joke yeah yeah
yeah so my manager comes running down
after my set and he's like you're about
to make a ton of [ __ ] money a ton the
key word is ton of [ __ ] because when
you told the crowd at new faces to shut
up everyone stopped looked and said who
is he because I didn't know I wasn't
supposed to you know what I mean like
it's a comic when the crowd starts boo
you're like [ __ ] you you know but but I
you know I'm not thinking like right now
I'm not supposed to do that so thank you
yeah thankfully my comic instinct or
whatever it was worked in that moment
and then and then I did a different
different set the second time and people
like wow you did a different Citizen and
I'm thinking it's five minutes like I
got ten yeah yeah I got ten I could do
five in a different five again my uh
being naive helped me it helped me
because I I did stuff that I wasn't
supposed to do and that's when they
recognized you right when you like you
talked about the guy being safe right
they recognize you when you take a
chance but to me I was just doing what I
do I didn't even think of it as taking a
chance and I think the other thing that
helps is if you start in LA or New York
the bar is so high you learn fast
because you're around the best you know
especially back then La was where all
the best comics from New York hadn't you
know like now it's New York and you know
yeah
so um
yeah that's so that's how it happened
you know dinosaurs roamed the Earth at
one time you know and they were
pterodactyls so so I go back in comedy
so far that
I remember Gary Shandling before Gary
Shanley was Gary Shandling and I
remember Howie Mandel before saying
elsewhere and all the things that he did
and I remember David Letterman when he
drove a red truck and was at The Comedy
Store
[Music]
um
you know Belzer
Tim tomerson John Fox Judy tenuta
um emo Phillips Kennison dice
um Arsenio
you know
um Robin Williams coming from more you
know come from Paramount to do The
Comedy Store still in his Mork and Mindy
outfit I remember seeing that and to
look back and think
that I saw an era that is gone is gone
prior
you know all that
I saw all that with my own eyes like I
saw Richard Pryor
in this Canary colored Rolls-Royce
between shows listening to his set on on
a on a cassette recorder and my friend
Ernie we were gonna I was gonna say
hello and then I got close enough and
I'm like oh [ __ ] he's listening to I
backed up you know and I spoke at his
funeral like you go from there to are
you legit Richard Pryor at his funeral
in 2007. uh eight and I mean you
the only difference is that in in the in
between is I think I didn't let anybody
dissuade me from what I thought I needed
to do what I felt I needed to do and in
this and in this especially now
everybody's about followers everybody's
about likes all that but it but
essentially
you have to be able to know your skill
you have to be able to know your craft
right at some point at some point funny
you have to be funny yeah at some point
you're not going to get by on [ __ ] that
you know is just works at home you know
on YouTube yeah and then the view I did
the view one time and they had these
reality people on and they were nowhere
because they're funny and then I was a
second guest and you're killing them but
then you're like oh [ __ ] I had you bring
out we should have had you first we said
yeah you should have but you're
intoxicated by reality TV yeah and even
even comedy clubs would use reality guys
or guys that on YouTube that were that
were popular and then they'd go out
there and
that have they have nothing I had a
period of my career where that was my
gig my gig was to make the show funny
because they had like the reality stars
or this or that and they were like yeah
but we need Comics that was in the early
2000s
um yeah that was in the early 2000s when
they would bring in one thing they do
they bring in soap stars because they
people like women came to the show and
then they would bring in
people who were yeah they were mainly
from reality TV or something like that
and but they would so they would it
would be their show but then they put
one or two real comics in there to make
sure the whole show was funny you know
so so you had the big name or you had
sitcom stars who were actors
uh it was on All My Children Willie uh
something he was he was an actor yeah
Walt Willie what will yeah and he would
go up there and he was in all my
children and he would perform as to what
he would do and then you know he was
working in clubs yeah yeah and you know
sitcoms a lot of sitcom actors are just
that they're actors they're not Comics
No they get they get offered all this
money so they go to a comedy club and
the people who ran the club knew like
okay we got to have some comics strong
comics on the show to make the whole
show funny and I I used to get that call
a lot Bill Burr talks about it bird used
to do that too where it's like yeah man
this is an alternative show so we're
gonna need you to make it funny right
what about the doctor the one that does
all the acting now Ken Ken Jung yeah Dr
Ken so I I came up with them I watched
him come up so he was he was like funny
and I don't know he was always a clown
he was always just you know first of all
likable super likable I used him at the
amphitheater super likable and he was
funny but he loved he loved acting like
once he became an actor that was his
thing and he would just do stand up on
occasion but you know that likability
man you know it's fluffy listen I
remember when fluffy bounced on stage
man it's giant yeah giant 10 I said it's
a giant 10 year old kid in short pants
right and people loved him like it was
it was like crazy like people just fell
in love with this guy right and then
he's very smart and very funny and grew
to grew it to a you know he's an Empire
now but um yeah I watched them come up
but it's funny when you talk about all
the guys in the 80s because George
Wallace George went from being one of my
mentors to one of my friends I love
George and George will always remind me
he said man lonza you're good you'd have
made money in the 80s you didn't you
ain't make no money I made money you
ain't make [ __ ] yeah you would have but
you didn't
because in the 80s you guys were getting
paid man right right that's exactly
right I remember when the guys you
mentioned Dr Ken
uh Iglesias you would all come with Rudy
over to speak yeah we all did you know
in the beginning we were all doing those
that was late 90s early 2000s uh Ralphie
May you know all of us were doing that
we were in that
early Club phase right where you just
start maybe headlining or it would be
like like you would come to the Improv
and do Friday Saturday right and I would
be your feature but I headlined on
Thursday right exactly that kind of
thing you know we were all in that
in that world and finding finding our
legs finding our names and uh and then
you know and then guys got breaks like
with Ken it was when he did um Knocked
Up
it was like he'd never looked back after
after doing that you know Craig Robinson
right did some of those did the office
you know and it was like boom so it was
you know I did Last Comic Standing that
changed stuff for me that was when
suddenly you're on TV and people
recognize right you know
um so yeah it's interesting because you
know like when I was on TV uh I think
Ray was on Damon was on John Ritter was
there Bonnie Hunt Bernie Mac
um yeah a lot of you dads were on uh
yeah
and I mean I I would have never I would
have never thought I would have had the
first show but also
you know every day a page turns to the
Past
you know every day you get you know you
can be something one day and gradually
if there's nothing to Anchor to those
pages keep turning and then they reveal
new people
and
when I did The Tonight Show with Jimmy
Fallon
um
like a month ago maybe for the new show
and as I was standing there and they
were ready to bring me out I remembered
standing behind the curtain in Burbank
with Johnny Carson and I thought
when I was behind the curtain in
November of 91
did I believe that in
2022 I would still be around I would
have to say no I would have never
thought that far ahead
but walking out there like it gave me a
sense of like uh of Peace man like that
you know you look at people that were
around 30 years ago not a lot of them
are around yeah we're watching the show
you told the story about because I had
heard the story about the watch already
yeah you wore the watch that yep uh
Johnny Carson wore yeah how about Johnny
Carson's Rolex that he had oh yeah 79 to
oh wow 92.
don't wear that or on male rules right
now that [ __ ] take me out
and and and do you see yourself do you I
don't see my I was married you know for
17 years
um do you see yourself married
no I have no regrets man no regrets you
know I I love this I've had a uh it's
been a great run and I'm still you know
it's the same way where I'm still
relevant like I'm still doing clubs you
know I'm still on search of course yeah
and you but you see like you said
there's always new ones coming up and
you look around and the people you knew
a lot of them they're not they ain't
getting spots anymore they're not doing
it anymore so so I'm like yeah man I'm
still still out of here the only person
you have to worry about is yourself yeah
yeah you got to keep well you got to
stay relevant I think as Comics as when
you get older you got to understand that
it changes right comedy changes language
changes this and that and if you're
still doing stuff
from 15 years ago like these kids can't
relate they don't know what you're I
know man they don't know what you're
talking about you know so you you have
to adjust and and respect what they're
doing right respect their culture and
what's coming up and um I'm in the place
now in comedy like I'm one of the ogs
like a lot of the young Comics they come
up to you like man I was watching you
when I was growing up and you got to
understand they're not insulting you
saying you're old they're saying like
wow man it's good to meet you like like
I learned stuff from you
that you you know you didn't even know
who I was but I was watching you you
know and that kind of thing but as far
as marriage and family I don't I don't
have any regrets because I've Loved what
I've done I still love it so I don't I
don't feel like I missed out on
something are you um were you all are
you an only child no I got a brother and
a sister
um so you have friends that are away
from away from oh yes yeah you know one
of the things I think helped me in the
business those 10 years in Aerospace I
lived and worked and made friends who
were real people not Hollywood people
yeah yeah so that that's always been
grounding like Thanksgiving I spent with
uh with people you know guys who I went
to high school with and their families
and stuff like that I think that's
that's always been grounding you know
what people get in trouble in Hollywood
man you've seen this you start believing
this [ __ ] is real right it will destroy
you like this I tell you I've never
gotten a job from someone who loved me
right man we love you we really want to
be in Alonso business right really
because my phone number's still the same
yeah so you don't love me that much you
know but but that it's seductive man
it's easy to fall into those traps
I always uh you know I started playing
golf when I was 21 but I've always been
a bit removed like I don't I don't I
don't uh
I don't have a lot of people that I'm
that I'm around but that's the way I
grew up so I have a house outside of LA
and I was at the house this weekend
and I golfed with somebody that I know
out there but then I'd go back to the
house and be happy just being alone
because that's the way I was when I grew
up it's like I still I'm still fit in
that template of my grandmother's house
in just another house they're not around
but you know I still like a little
interact I mean not interaction but
it's to me being at that house and just
chilling in in where it is to me and not
having people around
is what makes me happy like you know if
if I'm around all these people for the
last let's say solid 20 years not being
around people is to me what somebody
would say they enjoy being with friends
like I it's reverse yeah the um I mean
listen I rescue dogs not one of those
[ __ ] is going to call 9-1-1
when I have a heart attack they're going
to find me after the neighbors are
there's a there's a there's a weird
smell coming from that house
but you know the pandemic for me that
was if that was quiet for the first time
in 25 years yeah like things were quiet
and I was like man it's kind of nice
yeah so yeah I feel you it's kind of
good to get away from you it was kind of
nice to not like I'm not going to the
airport this weekend I'm not you know
and the crowds and and you know to the
people listening to we love you guys we
love the fans but there's times when you
appreciate being quiet when you leave
work like that's work but when you leave
work I never felt alone I never felt
lonely I've been kicked off Instagram
now for you know I don't know what the
[ __ ] I still haven't gotten back on I
haven't done but it does feel good you
know that used to consume my time what'd
you do I I didn't do a goddamn thing I
think some I think somebody tried to
hack at the same time I had hacked on
Facebook so I think somebody hacked I
don't know what they did I don't mess
around on that thing but they said I
violated their company
trying to get close to me
I don't know I got kicked off and so I
but
I haven't missed it either because I was
so busy you know just trying to because
I don't have anybody doing my own [ __ ] I
would I would answer it try to answer as
many I dated I dated a woman that you
know I think I lived with her I would
say I lived with her and in the morning
instead of reaching for the dick she'd
reach for the phone and you're like all
right so you're gonna scroll your phone
when you could be scrolling the dick
and there and for and and before you
know it 45 minutes have gone by yeah and
you're just looking at this phone man
you know like I I don't do my social
media
um because I prefer not to because I
just I just can't spend that much time
doing it but to but to some people it's
almost like finding out that wrestling
some of it's already pre-thought out
right like like I got hit by people on
Tick Tock for like not
um being the one who's posting them but
I got [ __ ] to do now and I'm [ __ ] 61.
at 61. I I answered almost every one of
them because I don't have somebody that
does it for me and I told the wife I
just don't want people to think I'm an
arrogant [ __ ] I'm just an ordinary
humble guy why you though you have to
find out what's going on why do you
think you got kicked off for who knows
were you answering people the derogatory
no no no there is not one thing
Instagram if you're listening I'd like
to know I didn't not one thing nasty not
one thing political nothing I did
nothing I just got this notice that and
and I didn't think much of it because I
thought I've seen on Facebook where
people said oh I'm in jail for 30 days
wait a minute I'm getting a message
right here oh you know what
Richard Ramirez daughter runs Instagram
[Laughter]
I bet I bet it had something to do with
that yeah I bet it had something to do
with that when that cake when that
documentary came out yeah people found
out who you were and somebody wrote
something but all they did I used to get
a lot of ugly [ __ ] and but I just
wouldn't answer yeah at all I I never
answered the people from Richard Ramirez
because they were real said I should be
dead instead of him I was a I never I I
laughed at it I'd never respond because
I'm sitting there saying hey I'm 72
years old if I got a life I got a job I
got I'm happy I don't need this [ __ ]
sorry because it is it is it is like
poking the Bear right it is it is like I
don't look at it for me it's easier not
to look at like I appreciate it for what
it is but I I'm not trying to engage or
be uh uh prodded by anybody to to I'll
answer it like I I finally found someone
who's really good at social media
because it's one of those things anyone
can say I do social media and she's
seven years old right whatever she is
she's been blowing it up she took my
specials she cut them up in yeah she
releases the clips my followers have
grown and all of that I'll answer you
know I'll try to answer people because
I'm like you like they're surprised when
it's you that answer yeah so I like
doing that but what they told me was
don't read the comments they said just
don't read it because if you if you want
the good ones then you gotta accept the
bad ones you got a lot of crazy people
out there and this and that so this and
and like you say you fall into that hole
next thing you spent two hours exactly
looking at now I will say one thing
that's funny man I don't know anyone
who's destroyed something as fast as
Elon Musk destroy Twitter oh my God it
was like overnight Twitter turned into
us just a pile of [ __ ] I mean just I
started getting porn stuff sent to me
and all this stuff and I'm like it wait
a minute I'll sign up no so he took the
filters off all I think you think are
you on Twitter no I'm not on Twitter you
know because when you're on Twitter you
get these you'll get an email like so
and so tweeted and it used to be like
different it was mainly comedians
because I follow a lot of comedians you
know this community between next thing I
started getting this you know mature
single chick wants you and blah blah
blah would you would you [ __ ] me in this
[ __ ] and I'm like where did all this
come from and then the hate stuff he he
stopped they used to filter the hate
groups and hate speech and he said no
you can do whatever you want and I was
reading a thing that it it like tripled
overnight the amount of direct hate
speech and these hate Club you know
white supremacist organization and it
was like you couldn't have planned to
ruin it as fast as he did you know it's
just so now I hardly ever go on Twitter
I might go on once in a while say I'm
going to be at this club or this and and
I've been telling the followers like I
gotta I'm gonna get off of here I gotta
back out of here somebody needs to come
up with something new right because
Twitter has just become
a mess but it's comical how fast it
happened
um
yeah here Jane font I haven't been on
Twitter in
so long Jane Fonda sent me a message I
have a movie called coming home I hope
you watch it
that's amazing
Al Pacino I did a movie about a Cuba
drug lord
okay so Jane [ __ ] so I haven't looked at
Twitter in a long time
um and Jane
see more Fonda which is Jane Fonda
hi George it's Jane my staff has told me
that you follow me and here and I want
to thank you for that how cool Lily
Tomlin are you we're not you're
reuniting uh more soon written by me
Jane not the staff okay
sorry James she was at she was
anti-American Vietnam
but also yeah like
um
yeah a lot of messages that have gone on
but I don't really want to look
there's a [ __ ] tunnel with me porno
girl right there
wow man porny that's why I missed that
one
um
but I haven't looked uh but
yeah
so so
you should say you got to sign up for
Twitter take a look okay so take a look
at my see how it starts out Jim Gaffigan
yeah blah blah then
what comes up next
oh wow man is that is that because of oh
man yes this just all
randomly started coming in
and here's Elon Musk yeah what the
what is he what's he doing dude what's
your thing yeah
oh how sad
oh man no I'm again it's not a matter of
being a prude or nothing I mean they're
fun to look at it's just when that when
that starts bombing your phone right
when your your phone because once it
comes in then it's like the algorithm's
like oh yeah yeah that's it we'll keep
sending it and then you know so
apparently I am very hot with single
mature women that's that's my
demographic right now so is that their
thing like that's that's that's seems to
be I'm on their list
I mean kim.com you ever see this dude
like kim.com that heavyset dude that got
his house rated
um
but
it is yeah dude
it is
um
it is different man it's different now
yeah and you know
some people are still like killing it on
there you know
but um yeah every time I get a list
do you uh
would you would you what's your perfect
scenario for you um
Ingrid wait a minute
um
that one for later no no no listen
Ingrid's going angry
it's funny
I prefer silence to [ __ ] has anybody
ever said that yes I feel you on that
man it's it's such a thing not in my
house you get to a certain point where
you're like you like man this [ __ ]
looks good but is it worth it like
because there's a lot that goes with it
you know what I mean
that's the part you start thinking about
you're like man it's gonna be you know
it's it's almost talk yourself out of it
it's almost like there's a there's a bio
a biohazard a [ __ ] balloon filled
with biohazardous material and you go
with a pencil what happens if I do if I
[ __ ] poke this and your [ __ ]
life's never the same man
now all of a sudden you activate it's
like activating the machine this is a
[ __ ] death right here oh yeah what
happens when you do that if as soon as
you put it in you've put it in Forever
you can't you can't put it in and
they're not gonna you might not you they
might not remember you might not
remember you [ __ ] them but they'll
remember that you had interest in them
oh my I have a friend like just you know
there's been no show TV show that had
that intro right
otherwise like oh that person never
dated never never hooked up or anything
right but we joke about dating stories
and I said
you know I'll tell them look I don't
want a relationship she said there is no
better way to lock a woman in than tell
her you don't want a relationship she's
like you might as well just say hey move
I'm looking for you to move in the house
because she said the minute they hear
that that and it's like I don't know how
to make it any clearer and she's like
nope that's not what they hear that's
they say [ __ ] we're trying to
crack the same challenge
you know not just anybody can crack a
safety shut the [ __ ]
if you tell somebody you don't want
something they're gonna want it's it's
the it's the opposite of it's a
challenge you rescue dogs and it's like
George we got this pit bull that eats
people and you're like not me yeah
I had a paper I rescued a pit bull that
I wasn't home when it arrived and when I
got there it was gonna [ __ ] attack me
and I couldn't wait to get that
[ __ ] and then the guy that I got
it from said I heard it didn't work out
it didn't work out [ __ ] if I [ __ ]
stood like this for 30 minutes
and the woman's like Google
sense of sphere cause I'm scared I mean
the gum went all the way back up to the
nose
I never met that [ __ ] dog
yeah man it's they you say something and
you think you're saying it clear and
they are here in the exact opposite
but it but in our society do we do we
give them do we give people the the
belief that when you grow up that you
meet somebody that they're take care of
you for the rest of your life well I was
just reading about this right so
um
there was an article that said there's
what more single people over 40 than
there have ever been in our society
it's like a higher percentage than we've
ever had single people who live alone
they said because you have some people
who never got married because careers
change and then you have people who are
divorced and never got married again and
this and that and they talked about that
they said as you get older
there's no one to take care of you so
you know you have you'll either be you
can be lonely or you can die young
so I sent it to uh my therapist I said
well I guess I'm a die young and alone
because I you know I I have a friend do
you feel like it
sounds like somebody's trying to turn
you almost like a viewer of another
gender you know trying to that have
women said like Hey listen I know you
don't want a girlfriend but you haven't
let me they don't work on you they don't
say it they just but they but they the
Smart Ones the Smart Ones just start
doing it right they don't say anything
they just they're just around more and
this and that and then suddenly you're
like wait I guess you're my girlfriend
now right the other ones claim it or
they get real jealous and stuff like
that and that's like I can't can't be
around that but I I have a buddy he's
about to he just got engaged for his
third time and he said man well who's
gonna wipe my ass when I'm 70 years old
and I was like does she know that's why
she's getting mad like
she signed up for the ass wiping in 10
12 years did she know that that was the
long term I don't think so I think she's
thinking love in the house and I said
that I don't think she you you be fair
tell her listen this is about ass wiping
it's all about cleaning
some cotton else
so you know they all want to have kids
so they have it he's older they have a
kid she'll have two in diapers they'll
be like him you you clean my ass so you
clean a baby's ass yeah that that's
another thing having kids older the old
dad thing no no no no man I don't want
to be you know wait I'm gonna be 72
years old old and I got a teenager you
can't had a car I'm taking the car well
okay take the car yeah
listen yeah I wouldn't want everyone
in my 60s that my first turn in my wrist
Dad we go into the ATM
you know I mean I was afraid of my
grandfather before we're more related
but probably that's why he had no blood
connection to me to [ __ ] me up he
would have went to sleep like nothing
happened uh but also
I had respect for him and and kids would
be like you're not you know
I I
this one time this kid I was dating this
I went with this woman had a kid and she
said you're not my dad and I said I'm
not but if I was I could pull someone
better than your mom oh and uh
it didn't work no it didn't work out my
mind you [ __ ] heard a kid's feelings
I wonder why like what did you say to
him I gotta say it again my best was um
I dated a woman I'd say dated we went on
three dates but her son is in the NBA so
I told her I'm claiming him
that's
you know I mean like like yeah I like
you know we were together for a while
and I taught him how to play ball when
he was young like that's my story I'm
running with that yeah yeah
he's good yeah he's good so so I can say
this now because it didn't happen so
so I'm at a Laker game about a few years
ago and uh this guy walks over tall
African-American guy with a with a black
leather vest and I think he had a cowboy
at him and he said hey uh George
Paul George senior
and I said oh hey what's up man how you
doing and I think Paul George is still
in Oklahoma and he said we went to the
same high school I said you went to San
Fernando High he goes I'm a year older
than you
so I graduated in seven year you
graduated in 79. and but I saw him play
I mean we used to go to the high school
so I'm playing and
um
I said to him is your son coming to the
Lakers and he said no nobody no at that
time nobody knew
that he wasn't coming to the Lakers
right except me
and I didn't say [ __ ] coming out so your
secret's safe with me gil yeah the
[ __ ] Hills I found a doctor
are good for your arches they're safe
with me the purple ones one of the
things when you know you're getting
older is when you can remember when
every coach played yeah oh my God
what about I used to go to I used to go
to [ __ ]
Dodger family games and
they would be playing the Giants and and
uh eight-year-old Barry Bonds would be
running around yeah
and and then they're on the other side
man like yeah they're retired what about
when you when I would go to the Dodger
Stadium I was younger than everybody
playing
and now I'm older than everybody playing
right now if they could be our kids they
could be our kids yeah yeah like I said
I remember there are some coaches I
remember when they played college ball
and they're coaching I'm like wait a
minute man I'm not I'm that old that I
remember
to generate or like there's a junior
playing and you remember when his dad
was in the league
Griffey Jr friends wait till you get as
old as I have you don't remember [ __ ]
let me ask you about your motorcycles
man yeah um what are the where did the
love of of cars the specifically
motorcycles come from uh when I was a
kid my grandmother lived in South
Carolina she had this farm and it was
like a dirt road you had to go from the
house to the main road right and some
people rented land from her and their
kid had a motorcycle and he would take
us for rides up and down what kind of
motorcycle it was like an old British
bike either Triumph or something like
that great bikes right yeah yeah and uh
I fell in love with it and and it never
changed like to this day it's still that
feel that guy right in that box yeah
it's still that feeling when I get on a
bike like I from then I always wanted a
motorcycle my I got a motorcycle before
I got a car when I hit 18 you know
they've always been um it's just a
feeling man just something about him and
the love of cars you know I just grew up
I don't know in that generation where we
loved cars like they say now like kids
grow up and they don't care about having
a car like when I was growing up you
wanted a car we used to read car
magazines you knew every car that went
down the street you knew what it was you
know what I mean and you had that like
my first car was a 67 Camaro you know it
was and that was you wanted that where'd
you get that car so I got it here and
the dude who stole it was nice enough to
let me finish it before he took it he
waited till I did the wheels
I put the stereo in it you know I had my
six by nines on the back shelf you
remember all that back in the day yeah
he he was like yeah this is turning out
really nice I'm gonna give you another
couple of months he said okay now I'm
gonna steal it I stole it from your
house no from that's when I was working
at Lockheed stolen from the lucky
parking lot yeah
uh yeah so Jill why don't you find that
[ __ ] for me man now I meet you I don't
need you if they didn't die I didn't
care that is the car
um and uh but uh but it's always that
love has always been there and it's
still there and the great thing is now
they it crosses over right so I get to
do like motorcycle companies invite me
to do stuff and I've done shows for them
and this and that doing Leno's Garage
you know hanging out with Jay and all
that is awesome yeah I I I like
motorcycles but also think that they're
very dangerous like for me yeah for me
uh when I was doing Blue Beetle in
Atlanta
um we were I was talking I was telling
my driver of how dangerous I thought
motorcycles were and how personally I
you know I've lost people that were
riding motorcycles but I loved them and
I was thinking about getting one and
traffic was backed up and you know why
it was backed up because a guy got in an
accident on a motorcycle so it's almost
like the universe saying hey man you're
I I hear you I know where you are but
here it is and you think what are the
odds of that yeah you did a movie that I
I wrote an Indian Motorcycle huge oh
yeah and
I even told the dude hey man I'm really
not you know into motorcycles I mean for
the part I will everything is blocked
off but in that month and a half that I
rode that Indian Motorcycle loved them
loved it enjoy it loved it which the guy
would say I will have somebody drive it
over there so no I'll take it I'll go
around in this area that we were filming
at and I mean it's just beautiful
um you got you got hurt on a motorcycle
didn't you yeah I did I did I um but
that was it was on the track it wasn't
on the street oh okay so I went down and
it's really funny so we do track days
right they group rents out the track you
go in you ride what was the track at it
was in uh
um
Bakersfield yeah that's right you know
you know um Eddie Van Halen and Alex Van
Halen had these Porsches and they have
high performance cars and they would go
and take other tires that they would
change the tires over there and they
would they would race each other on the
track and you think all right that's
it's safe because you're not you're not
in the road right you're in that we say
like you're in the track everyone's
going in the same direction and there's
no cops
little cops so so yeah so I you know I
came out of a turn too fast went down uh
broke my wrist so I don't know who
writes stuff on Wikipedia
but this whoever wrote it wrote such a
great story about me being a motorcycle
racer for Ducati and they said I said
I'm not changing that I'm that they were
like I'm not editing that that story
looks fit like motorcycle Racers are
like horse jockeys right they had
literally half my size I've been a
racist I see these guys like if you
weigh 125 pounds they're like no you're
too heavy we want someone like yeah but
this guy whoever wrote that story I was
like yeah that's much better than what
actually happened is that is that the
only injury is that the only injury you
had I've had I've broken my wrist twice
30 years apart when I was a kid on my
first bike you know when you get your
first bike you're stupid I was passing
somebody on the right they made a right
turn you know my fault and I stuck my
hand out to you know to break the fall
and I broke my wrist and then literally
30 years later it happened on on a track
but I'm aware of the danger
um I think this is what I tell people
they talk about the dangerous at first
you got to live through your 20s right
because in your 20s you're an idiot and
you're you're indestructible that's
right and you so you you have to live
through that and learn to respect it but
what really helped me was when I learned
this guy told me he just said amen just
remember they're all out to kill you
like you said when you ride you just
keep that awareness like you just it's
not about everybody just ride like
everyone's out to kill you and you you
just become more aware of what's around
you and stuff so I'm aware of the danger
you know I'm not going to say it's not
dangerous it's not as dangerous as
people who don't ride motorcycles think
it is right and then also as you you get
older you become you become more aware
you become more cautious you wear you
wear the right stuff you know I'm not
riding in a
T-shirt and flip-flops and stuff like
that you know because again that that
it's just like that you know it you
suddenly you got skin grafts and
everything else so
um so yeah I respect it but I still love
it it's it's not something I don't I
couldn't imagine not doing it right okay
right now
um BMWs I I came in on a BMW Cruiser
called the r18 and then I have a couple
of BMW street bikes but I'm I'm always
like I don't collect I don't have you
know a warehouse somewhere where I
collect a bunch of stuff I want to ride
whatever I have so I'll have something
for a few months a year they're gonna be
like oh I want to try that bike and I'll
just trade it in you know sell one ride
and that was never like that if I if I
bought a car I I'd prefer to to keep it
and then to swap it out again which is
no nobody thinks like that about three
or three of them I started out with a
350 Honda 750 Honda then I went to a
Harley okay the Harley lowrider did that
for a while and then I loved uh I loved
my Harley
and it was cool just my daughter at the
end of one year that I had it
wrecked two cars and so on and neither
one of them were her fault but they were
used vehicles and so we didn't get [ __ ]
on them right so I ended up one year I
had three cars in a Harley so I had to
get rid of the Harley to get cars but
but it's different than being in a car
yeah
you're 100 you have to be aware of your
surroundings yeah but the thing is
you're in your surroundings right you're
you're like part of it like there's
nothing around you insulating you like
for instance you know I was late coming
here right but but I'm not texting while
I'm riding right whereas if you're in
the car you might be calling hey George
I'm 10 minutes away I'm 15 minutes like
when you're on a bike even though like
they have some of that technology now
they have Bluetooth helmets I'm like the
last thing I want to do on a motorcycle
is be on the phone like right that
that's just no I don't like the card
type of Walker a guy walking a tight
rope with a [ __ ] pole yeah a second
let me call you back when I get to the
other end
um what what's your what's your favorite
ride like like what what right here here
Mulholland Drive you know Mulholland
Drive up uh above Malibu yeah like in
that area yeah that that to me that's
almost like meditation just the curves
and you can the ocean is down there and
you get there's a point where you get
away there's no houses no cars it's just
a road it's just a winding road down to
the beach that's yeah that's where I
that's where I want to be that's that's
my yeah yeah my Escape run that in the
desert the desert is is nice because
when you get out in the desert like I
grew up in New York so I had never seen
that much nothing right you know the
first time I drove from LA to Vegas me
and a few of my boys from New York we
were like yo man yeah I know man that's
crazy there's nothing like this nothing
nothing you know and when you grow up in
New York there's no such thing as nut
there's something everywhere right yeah
there's something everywhere so and so I
just loved it it always blew my mind go
out there and just see like man you
could just you could go all day and just
not see anything it has a certain Beauty
to it and a piece to it and you write in
the morning you're right in the evenings
uh I well a lot of my riding is just
commuting just places I have to go but
when I go for fun generally it's in the
morning but in the summer when it's
really so those days where it's a
hundred and ten yeah then you go out at
night and it's like a perfect 80 degrees
and the road's quiet and that that's
when night riding is great when I drive
out of town uh like I left town this
weekend I leave at
4 30 or something like 4 or 4 30 right
around in there not after Never After
Five because I like to be out there and
see the sun come up while I'm Dr while
I'm driving yeah that's beautiful and
that and then there's no traffic but
also it's very Serene it's like a it's
like a perfect combination of driving a
car that you would that you love and the
timing of it uh with the sun coming up
right that's when you get to enjoy the
vehicle and and whatever right whatever
it is you're in and some of those things
are made are made to dry fast oh
absolutely yeah absolutely motorcycles
mean to drive fast I always say like
here in L.A like when I see guys
you know see people driving a
Lamborghini or or a Ferrari or something
and they're sitting in traffic I'm
always like wouldn't you prefer Rolls
Royce like if I if I had you know say a
300 400 000 car in La yeah it's gonna be
a Rolls-Royce because chances are I'm
sitting there I'm not I'm not going to
enjoy a Lamborghini right on the 405 no
but a Rolls-Royce
looking like a tank beautiful beautiful
cars
all right so thanks for coming in
brother man I love you man it is so cool
yeah I'm always a pleasure okay where
can everybody uh where can they find you
uh alonzoboden.com is the website and so
funny
z-o-f-u-n-n-y on Instagram
that's that's it beautiful
and who's paying attention is my podcast
here on the all things Comedy Network
which I was just reminded of by a
producer who's like man would you
publicize your own stuff Gail's not on
Instagram so
all right